[Musique]
une gradues school c'est un concept un
petit peu nouveau dans le monde
académique en France en fait il s'agit
de faire travailler ensemble des équipes
de recherche et des équipes pédagogiques
qui assurent des formations au niveau
gradué c'est-à-dire après la licence
donc en gros on s'occupe de parcours de
Master puis de doctorat donc on va
jusqu'à bac + 8 dans la Graduate School
dont je m'occupe donc la mission
principale des graduations en fait c'est
de faire de lien entre la formation et
la recherche donc les nombreuses équipes
de recherche qui sont présentes ici sur
le plateau de Saclay et pas seulement et
puis donc les équipes qui assurent les
formations donc au niveau Master et puis
pour les doctorats en fait ce sont les
mêmes équipes qui font à la fois la
recherche et l'encadrement des
doctorants donc le principe des gradués
school c'est d'associer toutes ces
équipes et de réfléchir ensemble à des
nouveaux parcours de formation des
projets de recherche en fait coopérer
puisqu'en fait dans la graduel school
biosphera donc je m'occupe nous avons 7
grands partenaires cette institution
donc trois organismes de recherche dont
l'inrae on trouve aussi le CE le CNRS on
a trois universités donc Université
Paris Saclay et des universités qui sont
dites associées à Paris Saclay donc Évry
et puis Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
puis donc on a l'école ingénieur agro
Paris Tech à laquelle j'appartiens
ce qui est intéressant dans les
graduations en fait c'est que c'est la
première fois que sur le plateau de
Saclay les acteurs de la recherche et de
la formation travaillent vraiment
ensemble de façon concertée à travers
cette structure qui est commune en fait
pour les étudiants un des avantages
c'est d'avoir accès à des laboratoires
de recherche qui sont connus en France
et dans le monde qui font une excellente
recherche dans les domaines de la
graduée School et pour les équipes de
recherche inversement ils seront plus
impliqués en fait dans les formations et
donc pourront encadrer les doctorants
des stagiaires et profiter en fait de
cette synergie entre la formation et la
recherche
dans la graduelschool biosphera en fait
on s'intéresse à la biosphère donc le
vivant on s'intéresse à la biosphère
dans son environnement qui est aussi
social politique économique donc
relation entre société humaine et
biosphère et bien sûr c'est
particulièrement important quand on
pense aux grands défis sociétaux que
nous devons relever que ça soit les
changements climatiques la sécurité
alimentaire la santé globale incluant
celle des écosystèmes la préservation de
la biodiversité ou le passage à une
économie qui serait basée non pas sur
des ressources fossiles mais les
ressources biologiques donc on retrouve
finalement la biosphère au centre de
toutes ces transformations et c'est ça
qui fait l'originalité et la richesse en
fait du projet porté par biosphera
[Musique]